oh by the way I know you spent all night
with Mariah besides premier you also
went to her party that I did and riot
celebrating the release of her new
breakup song and Kevin trust me when I
say you do not want to mess with me me
the wedding dress moment is such a
moment what prompted that decision the
moment how could you not it was a fire
pit there was a dress he's going on the
fire and burning what's the big deal
we're calling this Mariah's guide to
surviving a breakup first you write a
song about splitting from your
billionaire ex-fiance you call it I
don't and then you burn a wedding dress
in the music video is this some closure
for you now you know what I think that
everything is cyclical and you know it's
like things come back around and people
are happy and go through things and
that's just the way it is that's kind of
the way I feel about
ashtag I don't is trending I think it
should be hashtag don't mess with me me
by the way darling if you like it I love
it
the next step you take your new
boyfriend backup dancer Bryan Tanaka to
the exclusive release party for your new
single at catch LA what is the most
romantic thing about Tanaka overall
romantic yeah amazing
and finally you stay focused on your
friends especially when they're Beyonce
as a mummy of twins have you reached out
to her yet have you talked to her last
time I saw her was during Christmas and
she came to my show and she brought her
daughter it's really really sweet I just
I wish her and Jay all the best yeah
it's really hard having twins
there's nothing like it they're the best
they are they crack me up when they talk
to each other they have their own little
conversations they have like their own
language I mean it's it's kind of
amazing
[Music]
you